con un simple escaneo con un lector de código de barras
rápidamente se obtienen los historiales del paciente.
No es necesario volver a escribir sus datos personales
en el historial en papel durante cada visita.
Y, de repente, las colas se hicieron más cortas.
Esto significó que pacientes, generalmente madres con niños pequeños a sus espaldas,
tuvieron que pasar menos tiempo esperando ser asistidas.
Y si pierden sus folletos,
sus historiales aún se pueden extraer buscando por nombre.
La forma de pronunciar y deletrear los nombres varía tremendamente.
Mezclamos libremente Rs y Ls,
versiones en inglés y vernáculas de sus nombres.
Incluso con soundex,
un método estándar para agrupar palabras por lo similares que suenan,
no fue lo suficientemente bueno,
por eso tuvimos que modificarlo
para ayudarnos a vincular y unir los historiales existentes.
Antes del iPhone,
los ingenieros de software desarrollaban para computadoras personales,
pero desde nuestra experiencia,
sabíamos que nuestro sistema de energía no es lo suficientemente confiable
para computadoras personales.
Así que reutilizamos terminales de punto de venta con pantalla táctil
destinadas a tiendas minoristas
para convertirlas en estaciones de trabajo en clínicas.
En aquel entonces, importamos dispositivos de Internet llamados i-Openers
fabricados durante la era de las puntocom
por una compañía estadounidense fallida.
Modificamos sus pantallas,
agregamos sensores táctiles
y su sistema de energía para hacerlas funcionar con baterías recargables.
Cuando comenzamos, no encontramos una red confiable para transmitir datos,
especialmente en los hospitales rurales.
Así que construimos nuestras propias torres,
creamos una red inalámbrica
y clínicas vinculadas en Lilongwe,
la capital de Malawi.
(Aplausos)
Con un equipo de ingenieros
trabajando dentro del campus de un hospital,
observamos que los trabajadores de la salud usan el sistema
y construimos iterativamente un sistema de información
que ahora gestiona los historiales de VIH
en todos los principales hospitales públicos en Malawi.
Estos son hospitales que atienden en cada uno a más de 2000 pacientes con VIH.
Los trabajadores de la salud que solían pasar días
contando y preparando informes trimestrales
están produciendo los mismos informes en minutos.
Y expertos en atención médica de todo el mundo
ahora vienen a Malawi para aprender cómo lo hicimos.
(Aplausos)
Es inspirador y divertido
seguir las tendencias tecnológicas en todo el mundo,
pero para que funcionen
en entornos de escasos recursos
como los hospitales públicos en el África subsahariana,
hemos tenido que saber de todos un poco
y construir sistemas completos, incluida la infraestructura,
desde el principio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)